[Music]
I've lived in a world of death I've
watched people I've loved I originally
ten years ago I was going to do this one
the Hispanic the Mexican one and then I
thought about oh I just heard about
Burma and that it's the longest civil
war nobody knows what's going on and
there's jungles and it's heat and I go
I'm there you know I'm not done with the
headband you know so I did the Burmese
thing and then I said does anyone really
want to see and what's happened in
America it's become such an issue this
human trafficking it's really really bad
I thought let me get in the mix of that
and he now he has a family he has kind
of an adopted daughter her grandmother
and it's the only thing yes out of his
entire world was wandering around and
may have be enough to his waist and
blood he finally has peace but just on
the bow just on the boundaries of his
ranch he never wants to go off it
because he knows he has no control to
the girl certainly is and you co-wrote
this movie why Mexico because Mexico is
such a hot topic in America at the
moment so you probably had to approach
that with some caution
I did but I said you notice be honest
here Mexico is is having its issues and
and and a lot of people down there I'm
sure my dog oh god I wish this crime
would stop but it was misrepresented
originally taking on the cartel he's not
it's just a small group of people that
are dealing in the trafficking they're
not taking it's not a drug thing at all
that arm is very small so it's
believable containable it sees like
lowlifes I mean real bottom feeders that
Rambo unfortunately gets involved with
there seems to be a sense of this is
America's problem as much as Mexico
because you coexist you are side by side
it is it is because the you have for
example 18,000 girls being transported
every year and disappearing into America
from Mexico
that's it gone and people don't realize
that I I don't hit it as hard as I could
but I'm hopefully that people realize
this a serious serious problem but yeah
it's something that is definitely a CO
issue yeah did you find it difficult to
approach because it is such a complex
issue and like you said a huge issue if
you're not getting preachy on it and
you're keeping it okay you're making a
certain kind of film that's a suspense
in it but you're not making it a
platform to criticize anybody I think
it's pretty obvious that this gigantic
failings on both sides is interesting is
it because you you come back and revisit
Rambo you come back and revisit Rocky as
well there are these big strong
characters that you can't seem to let go
and it's interesting isn't it because in
Hollywood they always talk about there
being very few good roles for older
women there seems to be the good roles
out there for older men is that the case
not like the word no I think there's for
a few guys that are into the franchise
business they're there and there's a you
know random thing for maybe Tom Hanks
here and there but everything is
everything is imploding it's very small
where he understood is making 40 movies
of Maliki making 12 and 7 of those are
pretty generic kind of action films this
and that there's very few of those
dramas you have to go to cable TV that
that's where that's at Rand I was
probably one of the first big on-screen
characters to really highlight mental
health he deals with PTSD and it's
something that continues throughout the
franchise
we talk about mental health a lot more
now particularly when it comes to men is
that something that you're very open
about in terms of you know Rambo rocky
judge dredd they're all testosterone
fueled films but with Rambo you get the
sense of vulnerability as well and it's
important to show both sides of a man
yes I can't speak for women I can speak
for men that as the world becomes more
technological as it becomes more easy as
it challenges diminish it's taken a toll
I believe here because there's something
about having to go out and prove
yourself and be challenged that I think
is very important that's where sports I
think that's the dynamic of sports oh
we're going to play now there's
something about the guy I want to see
how tough I am I'm gonna see how far I
can push it so these kind of characters
especially Rambo he you know where does
the warrior going there's no war and
you're not accepted back home so he's
got that kind of issue
Rocky's another thing you remember a
fighter is peaked at 38 30 set he's done
like you're just you don't know anything
else where do I go for the next 50 years
I'm just a a dog yeah fight back then
you were pretty good so he's caught in a
time warp interesting so how does he
kind of keep ahead of the curve again
I'm not answering your question fully
but I that mental health is is on the
rise because of diminished opportunities
to physically challenge yourself